No More Tears on the label but it does
make you cry I know
a trusted brand used at homes all across
America for decades calc product causes
ovarian cancer
's baby powder
Johnson and Johnson is likely the most
recognizable household brand in the
entire world they've been around since
1886 and they dominate dozens of
industries from Pharmaceuticals and
medical devices to consumer health and a
baby shampoo they're currently the ninth
largest company in the world coming in
at a monstrous market cap of 432 billion
dollars but it's not just their market
cap that's monstrous because really the
entire company is monstrous while
they're fluffy white baby powder and a
no-tier shampoo comes off as seemingly
harmless if you look at their history
you'll find that the company is anything
but that like any corporate giant J J
has been willing to pull whatever
strings and go to whatever lengths to
maximize their market share and the
profits whenever someone like apple or
Microsoft does this while it's frowned
upon it it's usually not that big of a
deal worst case scenario you end up with
an iPhone that you can't repair or
software that's filled with bloatware
but when a Healthcare company like jnj
does this the consequences are much more
deadly literally over the years jnj has
been allegedly responsible for the death
and suffering of millions of people and
to make things worse these disastrous
consequences were often not a result of
an honest mistake or oversight more
times than not they were a result of a
negligence and ignorance this is why
many argued that the jnj has the
bloodiest hands in the Fortune 500 but
how did a family company evolve into
being such a ruthless predator
foreign
taking a look back Johnson and Johnson
did start off as a wholesome family
business as the name suggests it was
founded by the Johnson family but there
were actually three Johnsons in the
business not just two this included the
brothers Robert Wood Johnson the first
James Wood John Cena and Edward Mead
Johnson while Jan Jade did start off as
a family business it never really went
through that stage of being a
bootstrapped garage startup you see it
Robert was already a pretty successful
businessman having founded a company
called the seabarian Johnson which
produced sterile Searcher equipment by
1878 this company alone was producing at
ten thousand dollars per month in
profits that itself is a solid number
but when you account for inflation it
becomes 296 000 per month so yeah Robert
was killing it unfortunately though the
founders would end up having a
disagreement and Robert would eventually
leave the business but not before
becoming extremely wealthy combine this
with the fact fact that his brothers
were also well off and talented in their
own right and starting up Johnson
Johnson was a breeze the trio had a
capital knowledge experience and
connections from day one so they hit the
ground running they hired 14 employees
and launched a line of ready to use
surgical supplies and that marked the
beginning of jnj in 1886. over the next
few years the brothers aggressively grew
their product line and made history
within the surgical industry they
produced the world's first aerosurgical
products including sterile sutures
cotton and the gods and in 1894 they
launched their signature baby powder by
this point J had only been in business
for a mere eight years but they were
already employing 400 people and running
14 in buildings not to mention it they
were also becoming a household name but
just because they were successful and
Rich did not mean that they were evil or
unethical in fact there is very little
evidence suggesting that any of the
brothers had ill intentions or moral
motivations there's actually a bunch of
evidence suggesting the exact opposite
during the Spanish-American war for
example jnj donated 300 000 surgical
dressings and created trauma stretchers
for the soldiers they also made
substantial donations to the relief
efforts of the 1990 Galveston hurricane
and the 1906 San Francisco earthquake
and these weren't just for publicity
either and you could tell based on how
they treated their employees for example
when the 1901 smallpox epidemic hit J
would sponsor the vaccination of all
their employees similarly during the
Great Depression J J did not even lay
off a single employee they actually
raised wages by five percent jnj was
also ahead of their time when it came to
incorporating women into the workforce
eight out of their first 14 employees
were women and over the next few decades
women accounted for roughly half of
their company's Workforce and led a
quarter of their departments but then
how did such an Innovative
forward-thinking and a generous company
devolve into what they are today well it
all started with the brothers dying off
one by one Robert was the first one to
go in 1910 dying of chronic kidney
disease 22 years later James would die
while returning from a vacation on the
RMS Majestic and finally in 1934 Edward
would pass away from a heart attack
within just 10 years of the last founder
dying J J would be taken public in 1944
and that marked the beginning of their
moral free fall
Johnson and Johnson didn't just become
an immoral overnight though after all
the company was led by the brothers
children who carried many of the same
values and the principles as the
brothers themselves in fact when the
company was taken public Robert Sana
Robert Wood Johnson II wrote an ethical
guidelines book called orquito this
document outlined how choices had been
made at the company for the past 60
years and how they should continue being
made moving forward essentially the
Creator advises leaders at the company
to put the needs and the well-being of
the people they serve over profits and
it looks like this is what they were
doing at the beginning a perfect example
of this was the Chicago Talon deaths in
1982 seven individuals in the Chicago
metropolitan area were to All Die
shortly after taking an extra strength
Tylenol it turns out that someone had
taken the Tylenol offshore shelves and
laced them with Cyanide and then put
them back after hearing about this jnj
didn't even hesitate date to recall all
31 million bottles of Tylenol on store
shelves and replace them with new
Tylenol that came in tamper-proof
packaging this immediate action was
praised around the world as being the
gold standard for corporate crisis
management but with time it seems that
the jnj has drifted further and further
away from this gold standard starting
off with small infractions here and
there a perfect example of this is the
illegal marketing of Risperdal if you're
not familiar with the Risperdal it's an
antipsychotic that's used to treat
schizophrenia bipolar disorder and
irritability caused by autism Risperdal
has been instrumental for many people
over the years but like any medication
it comes with side effects and it's not
applicable to everyone one group of
people that should not take risperdala
is older adults with a dementia related
psychosis and this was crystal clear
since the medication was approved by the
FDA in 1994. nonetheless jnj paid
Omnicare who is the largest
pharmaceutical supplier for nursing
homes to promote Risperdal and it was
until a whistleblower out of J in June
2010 it that they got caught and the
penalty for this despicable Behavior was
a mere 2.2 billion dollars for
perspective J profits 20 billion dollars
per year which means that this penalty
cost them a little more than a month of
their current profits this is just the
tip of the iceberg though jnj has also
been linked with the Forum bribery
apparently their sales reps paid doctors
in Greece Poland and Romania to sell
medication and medical devices they also
bribed officials in a rock to win
contracts and the fine for all this a
measly 78 million aside from this jnj
has also gotten a lot more aggressive
when it comes to protecting their
patents when we're talking about patents
related to medical devices and
medications that's at least
understandable they usually have to
invest hundreds of millions if not
billions to create these products so it
makes sense that they don't want to get
ripped off right after launch something
that doesn't make sense though it is the
fact that jnj has previously tried to
prevent the American Red Cross from
using the Red Cross if you didn't know
it Jay and Jay actually owns the
trademark for the Red Cross symbol and
in 2007 they suited the American Red
Cross to stop using the emblem yeah I
don't think anything more has to be said
about that while these Petty lawsuits
corruption and marketing are inexcusable
in themselves it turned out that J and
Jaya actually had much darker Secrets
behind the curtains
one of the biggest lawsuits that has
plagued jnj recently is the baby powder
lawsuit it is alleged that the taco
based powder that is Iconic to their
baby powder is actually contaminated
with asbestos the obvious reasoning for
this is that the mines in which taka's
mind are often lined with asbestos so
it's only natural that the talc is also
contaminated with asbestos but it was
assumed that J J had procedures and
protocols in place to ensure that
asbestos wouldn't show up in the final
product J and J of course insists that
they do indeed have such procedures in
place and they deny all allegations but
this didn't stop 40 000 cancer patients
whose cancer may have been caused by
asbestos from banding together and find
lawsuits against the jnj and the
evidence that surfaced since then is
disturbing it to say the least allegedly
jnj found it asbestos in their talk
multiple times as early as 1972 but they
did and even notify the FDA instead of
making change jnj has opted to use legal
loopholes to avoid liability which came
to light just earlier this year through
Reuters apparently J created a highly
confidential planning called project
Plato the planet entailed to creating a
new subsidiary and then shifting all the
lawsuits to this new subsidiary from
there the substory would declare
bankruptcy which would push the cases to
bankruptcy court and substantially
reduce payouts there are even
allegations that jnj tried to get a
federal judge to block Reuters from
publishing their findings I don't know
about you but that's highly sus to say
the least and that's not the only
Scandal that jnj has been caught up in
either jnj has also been embroiled in
opioid lawsuits for the past several
years as well if you're not familiar
with opioids it's a substance that acts
on opioid receptors to produce
morphine-like effects it's usually used
in pain relief medications and
anesthesia and it can be instrument
Mentor when used properly but if it ends
up in the wrong hands it can quickly
lead to drug addictions and the deaths
due to overdose you would think that
pharmaceutical companies would be
extremely careful when it came to
Distributing opioids but they were
actually doing the exact opposite
between 2006 and 2015 opioid companies
spent 880 million dollars on lobbying
efforts to keep opioids easily
accessible fortunately all of this did
eventually come to light and the
pharmaceutical companies including J J
agreed to a settlement of 26 billion
dollars at the beginning of this year
but this doesn't really mean anything
because the damage has already been done
since 1999 760
000 people have died due to drug
overdose and that two-thirds of these
debts in 2018 involved opioids
personally I don't think jnj can ever
wipe their hands clean it after this one
foreign
extremely popular to hit on the biggest
tech companies in the world whether that
be apple Google or Facebook but what I
think we really need to focus on is
these background companies that no one
ever talks about or questions such
companies aren't just collecting our
data or selling us overpriced products
they're literally ruining lives and
that's not my opinion that's a fact not
all the lawsuits we discussed in this
video are complete but many of them are
and you can go online and read more
about it just how ignorant and
complacent all these pharmaceutical
companies have been and it just how
little consequences they face for their
actions after hearing all this I know a
lot of you guys will want these
companies to be shut down but
realistically that's just not possible
while many of these companies engage in
terrible Behavior they're also critical
to the medical industry so it's not
possible to ditch all of them at the
same time what may be possible though is
to hold them more accountable by
spreading the word and that might just
get them to think twice before engaging
in such behavior in the future but
that's just what I think did you realize
just how monstrous these pharmaceutical
companies are comment that down below
also drop a like if you hope that these
companies feel the pain for once and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm hurry and I'll see you guys on
the next one
foreign